ん
re
dj
みなさんこんにちは
今日は
皆さんの
皆さんの夢を
壊すためにここに来ました
音楽には
国境があります
1934年
日本で
偉大な方が亡くなりました
国は
その方の塩いたに
国葬を執り行いました
そしてアメリカの
nbc
mbc じゃないですよ
故郷たっぷりな子じゃありませんからアメリカの nbc が
追悼の気持ちを込めてこの音楽を流したのです
wh
rar
none
goo
ああああああああ
me
goo
おっ
me
4 r
どうですか皆さん
これねー
大変ふざけた音楽なんですよ
これはかっぽれと言います
もともと
大阪の住吉大社
あの漁業関係の人が良く進行する
神社ですけれどもそこでを取られていた
住吉踊りというものが元になっています
豊年祭梅棒つ面白い名前ですね
豊年祭梅坊主という大道芸人が明治
んですね
日本全国に広めました
どこでこれを歌われていた彼を取られていたかというと
まず寄せ
僕の大好きな
三代目古今亭志ん朝がよくをとっていました
それは面白おかしく座を盛り上げるためにですよ
そして芸者さんが主演
つまりお酒を飲ん席でお客さんを楽しませるために
おもしろおかしく
ふざけて踊ったものなのです
さてっ
この曲を送られた人物
この形は
この方です
皆さんよくご存知の
東郷平八郎
鹿児島に縁深いですよね
どういうことが起こったかというと
国民は大変憤慨しました起こりました
外務省も抗議しましたよ
nbc けしからんとこんな音楽をこの偉大な方のためのね
葬式のために流して
もうとんでもないことだ
なぜこんなことが起こったのでしょうか nbc は全く悪意はなかったんです
持っていた日本の音楽の複数の日本の音楽の中から
このカープレイがいいと思って良かれと思って選んだんですよ
なぜかというと音楽的な背景
文化的背景がわからなかったためにこういう問題が起きたのです
あの音楽はですねターンなる音の連続でありません
そこには作った人のメッセージとか
時代のメッセージが込められています
その文化的背景がわからなかったためにこういう問題が大きたのです
次に
皆さんは
音楽は
喜怒哀楽を表すものと
信じています
それは
愛や憎しみやいろんな感じはありますよね
悲しみや
そういうものをね
表すと信じています
しかし
世界には感情が入らない音楽もあるのです
例えば南インドの音楽には
人間の喜怒哀楽というような
まあ
したない感情が入っていません
まるで宇宙的な客観的な大自然を表すよ
そういった音楽なのです
ちなみに目をつぶってちょっと聞いてみましょう
ん
pa
はっはー
me
me ん
ありがとうございました
目を開けたら僕が注入管でたら最高なんですけれどもいい
僕はこのが頑張りはから見なさいん
でもなんとなくまあそういう雰囲気は感じられます
日本にも
喜怒哀楽が流行らない音楽があります
それは
雅楽です
ふぅ
ありがとうございました
雅楽には喜怒哀楽が必要ないんです
なぜなら1300年前彼らが9月なあの続いていますが
宮廷の儀式用の音楽であって起動あ薬は必要ないんですね
儀式が厳かに執り行われることが目的であってそこに感情を必要ないんです
もう一つ面白い話をします
これも文化的なことなんですけれども
雅楽は1300年前から今までほとんど形を変えないで演奏され続けてきました
それはですね面白いルールがあるんです
た間にものを申さず
館での管です
まああの簡単に言いますと他の楽器に注文つけちゃいけないということです
僕の仕事と反対です
僕はいつも楽器に注文をつけています
すみませんそこのフルートな人ちょっと早すぎので遅くしてくださいとかすみませんと
なペット大きいすぎます
こっちのチェロが聞こえませんからもうちょっとやらかくやってくださいなんてことは
絶対にしてはいけません
僕の仕事と反対です
どういうことをするかというと一つ一つの楽器に一つ一つのファミリーがついてるん
ですね
一つあのひとつのファミリーが一つの楽器をずーっと継承してそうしています
ということはおじいさんからお父さんお父さんから子供を子供がまあ孫とかまあそう
ですね
演奏の方法を週日に守ることが一番大事なのです
あの音楽合ってると思いますか
我々の感覚から言うとまああってるっとも言えるけど合ってないとも言えるっていう
けどよくわかんないとこですよね
それが同時進行してるからお互いのルールが同時進行していって
あの症の人がをことの人にねちょっと小城すぎじゃないて絶対言っちゃいけます
それは日本のこらえから続いている和をもって尊しという世界なんですね
ですから1300年も
続けられてきたんです
次
世界で一番民主的な音楽を聴きましょう
me
うふふ
ni
nara
wh
uh
ダボ
ええええええええええええ
wh
ありがとう前
ジャズですまああの
全部聞けばよくわかるんですけど
ジャズは世界で一番民主的な音楽です
例えば4人いたとしますサックスドラムピアノベース
それぞれが自分の意見を主張する場があります
in please でーしょん即興演奏という形でですね
ですからその文化的背景をアメリカで育ったということがよくわかります
そうですよね
民主主義を大事にしてますからなるほどジャズはそういうところで育ったんだなぁ
僕はそう思います
このように世界には様々な音楽があり
その文化的背景を知ればより深く音楽を理解することができます
逆に言えば最初の問題のように
文化的背景がわからないと
まったく音楽がわからない
そういうことにもなります
1982年
僕は一つのリックサック思って
ヨーロッパを一人旅行しました
なんと2ヶ月です
よろパジェロ歩きましたずっと歩いたわけじゃないんですよ
電車で行って歩いてるはいっ
いろんな街はマーゴかしないかさ
そこでですねあの日本にはその一流の音楽がたくさん来るでしょ
だから音楽は聴けるんですね
そこの風土が部か知りたかったので育ったところの
空気や人々とか
正教会の壁を触ってみたいですね
石田単にこう寝そべってみたりもしました
体感したかったわけですよね
育った文化的土壌を知りたかった
一番最初に印象に残ったのはポーランドです
ポーランドの舞踊学校を訪れてノックしてですね
上がったわけですいません僕は日本から来ました
音楽を勉強しています
ポーランドの代表的なマズルカを取ってください
大変なことなんですよ皆さん1982年
ポーランドは共産主義ですよそこに自由主義かな姿勢年額洗ったってきたですね
いきなり踊ってくださいなんてありえない話です本当
かなり危険ですコンタクトするだけでも
でも先生はすごくいい人で
バレリーナを集めて
なんとマズルカを踊ってもらいました
そこで
そしてですねあなたも一緒に踊りましょうと言われて
僕も撮ったんですよ
そのときの光景痛いですか
たですよね
これです
大変だったんですよまずよかったいいのか
くるくるくるくるもあるんですねそんなことも知らずにね
自分も踊ってみたいなんて言っちゃったんですね
それがこの se
次に一緒に残ったのは
スペインです
スペインでいちばん印象に残ったのは
セビリアでしたなぜならセビリアを舞台とした音楽がたくさんあるからです
モーツァルト作曲
オペラドン序盤
寒いです
そして
ロッシーニ作曲オペラセビリアの理髪師僕はものですねこれも
入っています
もう一つ言いましょうか
ビゼー作曲
オペラカルメン
だからですね僕はセビリアを歩き回りましたから
すごく勉強になりました僕はカルメン指揮する時はもう鉢ですね
文化的背景も入ってますから
フィルはあの闘牛に通ってですよ
夜はあのフラメンコです
フラメンコに毎晩支えられました
フラメンコダンサーがもう感激してくれて持ってる某してもらったんですよ
闘牛士の役の時のお姉さんステップも教えてもらいました
その時の様子見たいですか
すいませんそれはありません
さっきいきます8一番最近あの印象に残ったのはギリシャです
汽車では
ペロポネソス半島という昔から聞きたかった時に行きました
どんな街があるかというとに丁寧
スパルタ a
オリンピア
そういうところがあります
ギリシャはヨーロッパ文化の元になっているところですからそれに
汽車の劇を次第にして音楽はたくさんあります
エディプス王とがですね
いろいろあります d 写真はをもとに1音楽もたくさんありますですから
汽車に行ってきました
オリンピアの印象に残っています
これはオリンピアの古代オリンピック劇場で走る北の勇姿です
実際走ってきました本当に全力疾走でもなど走ってんです
国は違いますが
キプロスというキプロスという国があります
キプロス島ってなりまして
そこには
ビーナスが流れ着いたという海岸があります
そこにも行ってきましたヴィーナスにはありませんでした
ここに流れ着いたんですね
墓地シェレの
ありますね映画ヴィーナスの誕生
こういうイメージじゃないですかね
このように
様々な家を訪れることによって
その文化的背景を知ることが自分の仕事にものすごくプラスになっています
皆さんも
大好きな音楽があったら
その背景にある文化的な背景を調べてみてください
まあ可能であったら行ってみてくださいそうするとその音楽がより自分に近く感じる
ことができるしその音楽をより深く感じることができます
最後にもう1回申し上げます
音楽には
国境がありますありがとうございました